ils sont près de deux tiers sur les onze
mille salariés du technocentre renault
de guyancourt a est vrai pour l'alliance
plusieurs activités mises en commun
notamment l'ingénierie avec le
développement de la plateforme du
véhicule c'est à dire la partie basse
d'une voiture au vu du contexte la
direction n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
sollicités les syndicats ont accepté de
décrire la situation actuelle au
technocentre en fait tout ce qui n'est
pas vue du client et potentiellement
quelque chose qui peut être développée
par l'alliance et doit d'ailleurs à
terme être développée par l'alliance et
peut aller sur un des marques de
l'alliance ont sans difficulté
d'intégration à guyancourt 4500 employés
dans le secteur de l'ingénierie travail
pour l'alliance qui sont au contact au
quotidien avec les japonais des échanges
sur les caractéristiques de chacun liés
aux différences culturelles
une grande partie des salariés du
technocentre reproche que la stratégie
de l'entreprise fasse plutôt des choix
de côté nissan plutôt que choisir des
techniques développées par nos les
salariés du technocentre
c'est surtout en visioconférence et donc
des échanges quotidiens
pas toujours facile à voir c'est pas
facile parce que les les japonais
protègent leur industrie et leur travail
et ont du mal à partager
à partager
alors favre à faire l'alliance a permis
de réaliser des économies
la synergie entre renault et nissan a
été chiffré à 5 7 milliards d'euros en
rauno le budget recherche sur les six
prochaines années de l'ordre de 17
milliards d'euros
en fait si on fait si avec les faits les
faits alliance on a un portefeuille de
50 milliards d'euros en termes de
technologies disponibles
le nouveau pdg de renault jean dominique
senard est pressenti pour devenir le
nouveau président de l'alliance renault
nissan mitsubishi